foreign
on social media recently I saw this map
going about in red are all the countries
mentioned in the Bible the map has been
posted and reposted now for a few years
and in the comments below there was some
confusion it doesn't include any
biblical references or explanation and
how is France there and not Jordan I
thought I'd put my degree in Biblical
history and languages to good use and
investigate this question for myself and
I came up with this map a Bible accurate
version you could say I want to break
this map down for you and explore all
the interesting historical and
linguistic tidbits I learned along the
way pack your bags and bring your sun
cream as we explore the countries
mentioned in the bible wait hang on
there's a problem with this title you
see when the Bible was written the
countries as we know them today didn't
even exist in fact the modern definition
of a country itself didn't really come
about until a few hundred years ago so
it's not very historically sound to say
that the Bible mentions actual countries
well except for some very rare and
interesting exceptions the title of this
video should really be regions or
locations existing within current
geographical boundaries that are
referenced to or mentioned in the bible
but that's a pretty long-winded title
for a YouTube video oh and there's
something else I ought to explain the
Bible there's no one version of it that
all Christians can agree on although
that would be nice instead each
denomination tends to have its own Canon
and translations meaning that different
places appear in different Bibles and
don't get me started on the Apocrypha
the Bible I'll be using is the new
revised Standard Version which is used
in Academia and biblical studies that
means I won't be using the Book of
Mormon sorry America all right that
wraps up my overly detailed disclaimer
hopefully I prevented any political and
religious flame Wars from erupting in
the comments okay let's get going I'll
be starting in the Middle East the
geographical region where the Bible
originally came from beginning with
Israel perhaps unsurprisingly this
country is by far the most mentioned in
the Bible in Hebrew alone the word
Israel is used
2485 times makes sense it's where almost
all of the Bible stories are set there
are so many biblical names that can
apply to this region from Canaan Samaria
and Judah and there are other
territories like Gaza and philistia that
represent the modern state of Palestine
moving eastwards and we have Mesopotamia
the land between two rivers a land
that's today known as Iraq the fertile
Shores left by the Tigris and Euphrates
gave rise to the ancient kingdoms of
Assyria and Babylonia both appear in the
Old Testament as Israel's larger not so
friendly neighbors the Bible is full of
various battles invasions and prophecies
about these two kingdoms in fact it's
believed that many biblical texts were
written and compiled in Babylon
somewhere between 587 and 539 BC a
period known as the Jewish Exile as they
lacked to Homeland the early Jews wrote
down their stories and laws in captivity
which gave rise to the Torah speaking of
rivers next up is Jordan today the River
Jordan marks the boundary between the
states of israel-palestine and the
modern day Kingdom of Jordan This River
has a very special status in the Bible
Joshua crossed it to conquer Canaan and
Jesus was baptized in it to conquer sin
in the Old Testament the people who
lived beyond the river Jordan were known
as the moabites sadly the people who
wrote the Bible didn't have very nice
things to say about them according to
the Book of Genesis the ancestor of the
merbites was the result of an incestuous
love affair between lot and his eldest
daughter it's fine the merbites wrote
similar nasty stuff about the Israelites
too traveling south is Midian a region
that's today known as Saudi Arabia it's
a dry and arid place and famous for
being the land in which Moses and the
Hebrews partially spent their 40 years
wandering the desert the highlight of
that Journey had to be Moses receiving
the Ten Commandments on Mount Sinai
today there's a bit of debate where that
mountain actually is most believe it's
jabal Musa in Egypt but there are four
other contenders found in Saudi Arabia
it's still uncertain but in the New
Testament the Apostle Paul says that the
real Mount Sinai is somewhere in Arabia
so there's that the question is does
that correspond to the borders of modern
day Saudi Arabia if someone figures out
the answer there might be a certain Lost
Treasure to be found
up north we have Aram AKA Syria and
Lebanon AKA Lebanon like Israel Lebanon
is one of the few countries whose name
is preserved in the Bible since ancient
times the region has been famous for its
trees most of all cedar trees which were
reportedly used to build King Solomon's
Temple the cedar has since become
lebanon's national emblem and even
appears on its flag further north we
have turkey in the Bible this region is
given lots of different names none of
which are turkey from Cappadocia
Anatolia the land of Hattie Cecilia
phrygia to pontus in the book of Acts
it's simply known as Asia not to be
confused with the continent Asia this
version is Little Asia or Asia Minor now
for something a little mysterious the
land of Ararat in the Old Testament it's
described as being a distant mountainous
region famous for being the place where
Noah's Ark landed After the flood but
biblical scholars believe that Ararat is
the Hebrew version of uratu a kingdom
which corresponds to ancient Armenia a
kingdom which in 300 A.D became the
first state to officially adopt
Christianity a decade or so before the
Roman Empire the final Middle Eastern
country I haven't yet mentioned is Iran
historically known as Persia the Bible
celebrates this nation for ending the
Jewish Exile and returning Israel to its
Homeland the book of Isaiah gives a
special shout out to its king Cyrus the
Great he is given the title anointed one
or Messiah Persia has played a huge role
in the history of the region and at a
time was one of the largest empires of
its day in fact the Book of Esther tells
us that its borders stretched all the
way from Kush more on that later to a
province called hoju which is often
translated as India hodu likely refers
to the Indus a river that flows through
modern day Pakistan despite this it's
where we get the English words like
India Hindu and that Biblical word hodu
so Pakistan and India congratulations
you've made it into the Bible there may
be another ancient reference to India in
the Bible in the book of Kings King
Solomon not only Imports cedar trees
from Lebanon but also receives a
shipment of gold silver Ivory and
monkeys from the land of Affair these
exotic Treasures have led Scholars to
believe that Affair is in Southern India
or potentially even Sri Lanka it might
seem far out but these eras have always
been wealthy trading ports famous for
exports of Sandalwood precious metals
spices Ivory and potentially even
monkeys the biggest candidate for the
biblical Affair is pavar a bustling port
at the tip of South India wherever a
fear is it's a long way from Jerusalem
that's for sure and that about wraps up
Asia here are the regions the Bible
references so far it's already a
geographical area from the spice ports
of India to the cold mountains of
Armenia but we're only just getting
started two more continents to go up
next Africa it might seem hard to think
of references to Africa in the Bible but
there are plenty in fact it's easy to
forget that Israel has a border with an
African nation Egypt being one of the
great civilizations of the ancient world
Egypt is a big player in the Bible
unfortunately however it mostly gets
portrayed as a villain if you've ever
read the book of Exodus or watched The
Prince of Egypt you'll be familiar with
the story of how the Hebrews were
enslaved by the Egyptians and how God
uses 10 persuasive plagues to help
unharden Pharaoh's heart in the rest of
the Bible Egypt takes a bit of a back
seat and leaves Israel well alone they
seem to have finally got the memo from
Moses a little language tidbit for you
all Egypt has a lot of names the
Biblical word for Egypt is mitsarayim
and is still used today in Semitic
languages like Hebrew and Aramaic the
name we use for Egypt is from the Greek
egyptos which is the origin of the word
Gypsy a derogatory term used against the
Romani people of Indian descent the
ancient Egyptians refer to their country
as chemet meaning black land a reference
to the dark and fertile Nile soil
traveling up the Nile and we get to the
land of cush a territory that is now
Sudan and South Sudan sometimes referred
to as Nubia Kush is a criminally
underrated African civilization They too
had pyramids their own writings and gave
their Egyptian neighbors plenty of grief
on the battlefield the Bible contains
plenty of references to the land of kush
one of which I've already mentioned
according to the Book of Esther it was
the westernmost province of the Persian
Empire although in reality Persia didn't
hold on to this region for very long
another interesting reference to the
people of kush is Moses's wife look at
the 17th century painting by Jacob
Jordans you'll immediately notice that
his wife is of African descent in the
Book of Numbers we learned that she was
a cushite woman while the kingdom of
kush historically can be found in Sudan
and South Sudan some references to the
land of kush seem to refer instead to
Ethiopia the Bible also calls the
kingdom Sheba you may be familiar with
the famous queenersheepa who visits King
Solomon's Temple after hearing rumors
about its Splendor to Ethiopian churches
today the Queen of Sheba has a very
prominent role the Ethiopian National
Chronicle the cabernergast traces the
country's Royal Line back to the Queen
of Sheba and King Solomon it's difficult
to know where exactly the kingdom of
Sheba is today but it probably was a
territory that existed along the borders
of modern day Ethiopia Eritrea Djibouti
and even possibly across the sea into
Yemen wow four countries and two
continents in one we complete our
African nations in the Bible with Libya
whose provinces get a brief mention in
the New Testament our Biblical map is
really starting to take shape but
there's one continent left to visit
Europe
[Music]
by the time of the New Testament the
region of modern day Israel Palestine
belonged to the Roman Empire during this
Pax Romana the Empire connected the
entire Mediterranean with a network of
busy shipping channels something that
the early Christians used to their
advantage shortly after the death of
Jesus in Judea Christian communities
began to spring up in coastal towns
along the Eastern Mediterranean
particularly in Greece the Apostle pulls
many Epistles were addressed to these
Greek communities whether that be to the
Corinthians at Corinth the Thessalonians
at thessaly or the Philippians at
Philippi Greece became an early hub for
Christianity and Greek swiftly became
the language of the New Testament and
then came Italy or more specifically its
capital despite a few references to the
province of Italia Rome and the Romans
are mentioned many times throughout the
New Testament there's even a book called
Romans the Eternal City would become
pivotal in Christianity status as a
world religion and for many people Rome
and Italy is the heart of the religion
today the New Testament references many
smaller provinces that can be linked to
the countries of Europe today there's
Cyprus Dalmatia which would become
Croatia and parts of Bosnia and
Herzegovina Macedonia which is in parts
of Greece and modern-day North Macedonia
sagithia which at that time would have
referred to Romania and Bulgaria there's
even a reference to spanian which is
likely Spain and Portugal too if you're
feeling generous in fact Spain might
feature in the Old Testament too in the
famous story of Jonah and the whale the
prophet attempts to flee God's Presence
by sailing west to tarshish scholars
believe that tarshish may be tartesos a
vibrant Port City in the south of modern
day Spain at the time it would have been
seen as the edge of the known world so
would have been a Fitting Place for a
hapless Prophet to sail in an attempt to
flee God the last place on our map is
potentially the most controversial and
that's France it's controversial as it
appears in a book that's not accepted in
all versions of the Bible in the book of
Maccabees there's a reference to a tribe
known as the ghouls the ghouls were at
Celtic people that lived in modern day
France Now France as a country is a
package deal because of its unique
political structure all of France's
current overseas territories are also
technically part of France places like
French Guyana in South America and
French Polynesia in the Pacific are as
much as France as European France this
means that by a sheer constitutional
technicality the Bible can conceivably
refer to Antarctica as France has
claimed to territory there if we are to
dubiously include France our map goes
truly International but because France's
inclusion is from a partially recognized
biblical text I'm going to pass socially
recognize France on my map just like how
France's claim in Antarctica is also
partially recognized sorry France
nothing personal there we have it a map
of every country that the Bible
references is your country there if not
should your country be on there I'd be
curious to hear whether the Eastern land
of sinim mentioned in Isaiah 49 12 could
be a reference to China of course this
map is heavily caveat by the fact that
almost all of these countries did not
exist when the Bible was written but
shout out to Egypt Lebanon Israel Persia
Cyprus Greece Italy and Spain that still
exist today or at least go by the names
that appear in the Bible this map is a
big Improvement to the one that often
gets circulated online even if I say so
myself for one it has neat references
down the side feel free to screenshot my
Bible accurate version and share it
around I have a high resolution one in
the description down below when you look
at this map from a distance you'll
notice how the majority of mentioned
countries are in the Middle East this
makes sense the Bible was written in
this region the biblical writers had
lots to say about their close neighbors
to the North East
South but
ler writers also knew of lands outside
the Middle East from the rich African
kingdoms of kush to the Exotic Maritime
ports of ancient India and potentially
Sri Lanka regions that lay on the
periphery of the Known World the map
stretches over a massive area it's
astonishing to think that the biblical
writers were even faintly familiar with
these places one explanation for this is
ancient trade routes you may have
noticed that many of these exotic lands
are mentioned in the story of King
Solomon's Temple and how precious raw
materials were imported from far away
places from the strongest Lebanese
Cedars to the finest Indian ivories the
temple was so luxurious it was even
talked about as far away as Ethiopia it
doesn't even matter whether King Solomon
was even real we know these geographical
regions exist today and the biblical
writers seem to nerve them as well used
as a historical document the Bible is a
snapshot in time into the Supreme
surprising world of early trade finding
Real World locations in the Bible
reveals just how connected the ancient
world was these biblical people knew
about their neighbors both near and far
even if it wasn't mapped out as
extensively as it is today come for the
Biblical history stay for a lesson in
geopolitics and early trade who'd have
thought
hey thanks for watching I really hope
you enjoyed this one if you like this
video and want to see more why not
subscribe a liking a comment also go a
really long way if you haven't heard
I've made an investigative podcast the
interruption available to download
wherever you get your podcasts oh and do
check out the Channel's merch over at
crowdmade we have beanies t-shirts and
hoodies links are in the description
down below
anyway I look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye